well paddington station is fairly quiet
this morning only a few passengers
because very few trains are actually
coming or going i think passengers knew
was coming and they planned
accordingly and this will impact
millions of people across the country
also coincides with some major sporting
events such as the commonwealth games in
birmingham as well as the first day of
the english football league however the
uh asleep union members say they simply
had no choice but to pursue this strike
action because they say many of the
members haven't had a pay rise since
2019 and because of inflation that
ineffective terms means that their wages
have fallen they basically want the
wages to rise in line with the cost of
living and that general secretary nick
whelan said they want to be able to
afford with their wages in 2022 the same
things they were able to afford in
2021. now on the other hand in the rail
delivery group which represents the rail
companies say that they need to deal
with the fallout of kovit and the fact
that passengers numbers have plummeted
the fact that they've been given grants
and loans from the government that they
can't continue in the same manner and
they've also accused
of a timing this industrial action to
coincide with these large sporting
events we have had people whose plans
are in tatters uh trying to get to
birmingham because one of the operators
the westminster is actually taking part
in this strike um we've also actually
spoken to sam terry just a few moments
ago the labour mp who was the shadow
transport secretary until he was sacked
by kier stama for joining the picket
line he said that he still supports
kieros dharma because
sorry a labor government is always
better than a tory government however
summer of strikes continues and there is
going to be a lot more disruption for
passengers in the next month